points per game is going to go way up
jalen brown excellent help defense there
[Applause]
gordon hayward out to brown
finds jalen brown boy that's good too
this is a confident team right now for a
team that's
in the ninth spot in the west oh you're
right you talk about it being a huge
game for them i don't think it phases
them as
beautiful offense by the celtics entice
the lay-in and the finish
brown causes the turnover
all the way to the basket is walker for
two at the early onset of this one
tice hands off to walker walker will try
three
that falls for boston cj with his first
bucket of this one brings the blazers to
within two with just under seven to go
in the first quarter walker will try an
early three and he gets that one to fall
they didn't have a lot of space either
but behind the scenes in his everyday
life
jalen brown long three-pointer gets it
to go
celtics blazers version of the celtics
marcus martin some ways
pocket pass deflected by the celtics
azonia tries to chase it down hayward
will let fly another
three and gordon hayward already three
for
four from outside three of this one
can't get it to fall two minutes left to
go in the first quarter tatum
operates against white side pull-up
jumper [ __ ] rattles in
celtics extend their lead to 13.
anthony against tatum gets down low
blocked by tatum back out azonia
mccullum an open three
won't fall an excellent start for the
boston celtics
tatum another three jason
and that's exactly what brad stevens was
telling him on the way up you got to
step
up be closer to him jalen brown
[Applause]
carmelo anthony completing his case an
early one that's a good sign
for miami they get over a third of their
points from three
the drive by brown off that baseline
here comes smart hayward and on top for
ties
finding brown defended by jones got it
what a beautiful turnaround by
jalen brown jones is there shot clock at
five under a minute to go in the first
quarter three
good you're derek jones you just take it
shake your hand but again
the ability by the heat in this first
quarter of dribble penetration is
creating a lot of offense
look at tatum aggressively takes it
inside count it for two and a foul
if another free throw puts it in
11-point lead for miami
walker with seconds remaining from eight
court good if it goes got it
got it nails that half court shot kemba
walker
the stoppage and had one brilliant game
here
in the nba bubble misses that one jason
tatum likes
whose first shot up and knocks it down
than you would think by his overall
demeanor
hayward short ball kept alive by tice
tatum
goes to the rim high up and off the
glass
come out and they're playing hard and
they're playing together
and they're playing different they have
a houston rockets mentality about trying
as brown
with that improved shooting knocks it in
smart kicks it back out brown's got a
good look for three that's good galen
brown
his second three-pointer
[Applause]
the lanky levert gets the ram shot
blocked jalen brown nice defensive play
lance thomas
aleutta brown tyson with a good pass and
jalen brown having one of those games
he's got 18.
well i i don't know if there's just one
because
they're right there they can play with
anybody as
tatum hits a late shot clock three
[Applause]
[Music]
taken and hit here's kemba walker with a
one of five
first half in the books
working on ciacoman gets free on a
screen from tice
got the shot away and in and a foul
finger roll won't go
tice is there to clean the glass he now
has nine
the other round what a great
transitional play for boston
difference of five seconds game clock
and shot clock are four and a half
seconds walker off balance good
that was a tough shot doesn't travel
gets the ball back
[Applause]
spins on false open jumper buries it tie
game
[Applause]
kemba keeps you all the way through in
the baseline nice little drop pass there
for tice
sells it down to 10 on the shot clock
tatum says i'll take care of that
he buries the three
tights rolling to the basket
go into the basket
[Applause]
good pass sweep i i
i was certain that jalen brown was going
to shoot that ball
his whole life to have the instincts of
smart and he probably won't have the
instincts
that's all you wanted to work on as
kemba knocked down the big
showing that size playing to that
advantage
big to big jalen brown their third
leading scorer on the seas
joel embiid being very intentional about
getting to the basket early here
shake milton has not shot the ball well
here in orlando
it's a two-on-one gordon hayward missed
the layup
and tatum missed the layup brown there
to tip it in
kemba walker great help defense gets the
steal kimball walker
was load managed very particularly and
intentionally and maybe it's gonna pay
off doris if he keeps making plays
like that with a quick burst to the
bucket
seven on the shot clock deep three goes
yeah i love that possession
tatum's got six rebounds in the game
that's a great job by daniel ty
sprint up the floor come back set a
screen get that man
wide open
walker great pump fake draws the hit
and one kemba walker coming alive
and you're falling
[Music]
tatum into the paint off the curl
whistle foul got it
jason tatum is here
16 now 18 points for
this one to the back court off the
deflection three to shoot
tatum kind of let it go for an extra
beat and he banks it in
sometimes you need to adjust even when
things are going well
because you know how the other team
wants to attack
and you know philly wanted to go inside
18 for jaylen brown 20 for tatum and 15
for walker make it 17.
[Applause]
here on the last possession they go the
half court trap but come back
man to man walker over the top
of harford tatum in particular but even
kimball walker and you've got to try to
limit that's a bad start dominant at
home
no there's no one back for brown all by
himself
and a couple of early baskets for jalen
brown the 23 year old with his left hand
mentally done
well and that's the kind of bucket just
like we said with jaylen brown get
yourself an
easy one early and maybe it gets you
going he's up the floor that's going to
compromise the sixer defense theta
misses a wide open three the ball finds
walker
he passes it up tatum tries another
[Music]
yeah we'll i'll take this all night bias
harris on the pick and roll it swings
around
milton's a very good three-point shooter
he got a great look if you get quality
shots like that you'll have a chance
tonight this is a team that with ben
simmons was a decent running team during
the year
[Applause]
tatum gets it back and this would be a
goaltend against horford
that's his game he's a spot up guy when
you make him put it on the floor not a
great finisher
kemba walker
brown's gonna try history off the screen
and roll with the jump stop
let me flash to the elbow seven two
seven foot two hundred fifty pounds and
make this easy jumper
walker inside great pass by tatum to
canter team against the clippers
remember
prior to the shutdown back in january
late january
here's jalen brown trying his second
three and connects
on his second three ball in transition
here come the celtics
kimbo with the pull-up three got it i
wouldn't want to be him right now
cross-court pass to smart marcus smart
from deep
and he drills it agreed a little side
pick and roll they
forced it out of his hands tatum down
low against shake milton
took it into contact counted and won
12 point lead 10 on the shot clock the
lob tatum
snuck back doran's inconsistent in that
regard but the movement
was excellent gordon hayward as the
celtics are off to a five-nothing start
[Applause]
brown and it rattles in smart a little
shaken up
siakim fell on him pascal just one of
four years walker in transition gets it
off the window to push the lead to eight
for the celtics
future the nba is in pretty good hands
brown rising canning of three over ciaco
and a foul that's three now on siakim
toronto still shooting under 30 for the
floor
here's tatum beautiful step through and
finish all year
walker to smart one second to go
good luck kemba good walker beats the
buzzer
you mentioned tops top scorer and on
both ends
tatum deep threes got 15.
obi on tatum on the far side walker
trying to free him with a screen
here's tatum gets it away in time
jason tatum falling down hits the
baseline jay
as the buzzer sounds van vleet
with the deep three doesn't go nabaka
offensive rebound
and digging in saved by jalen brown
great hustle play that time by brown
here's a three-pointer for the tie i
also think nick nurse saw
something with bouchet in there earlier
with ibaka so he can ride
the saw a little bit longer maybe
feeling more confident about the other
two
traditionally game three and four would
be in boston on the parquet floor right
now
walker i'll take this situation rather
than having to go to boston and play
walker and tatum running with the bench
now and in the air hanging it's a foul
on powell bleed so you got ciaco with
two
van bleed with two pow with three coming
into tonight and they certainly haven't
helped themselves tonight
tatum with band lead on him he's gonna
fire up a three oh
big hit for jason tatum toronto's
defense has been outstanding
another misfire between lowry and ibaka
another turnover third consecutive
turnover for the raptors brown
hangs and finishes and
walker gets free powell fell down walker
off one foot couldn't get it to go
in transition van fleet denied by brown
on the drive double team is there he
kicks it kimball walker
got it just as the timer expired and a
chance to go up 3-0 toronto does have a
foul to give walker of the double team
gets by
walker dishes ties with the dunk with
.5 left boston winning the first two
games had a blowout win in game one
kimball walker had a double double as
did tice there's kemba on cue
knocks down a triple you know they're 24
games for that championship run
it's by committee this year yeah no
kidding everybody looking for that
spotlight by the way
how about the blazer is tatum throat
playing so consistently during
this series he's shooting 56 percent
from three point of range
here's lowry on the drive denied mooji
nearly comes away with it
[Applause]
what boston playing well on the
defensive end it's turned into
transition points as tice running the
floor
throws it down everything to his right
gives it right back and brown throws it
down
oh my goodness
almost the rookie out of iowa state here
is walker and got it off in time
gotta come up with the ball you can't
give boston second chances when you're
down 22 points
kemba walker able to shake siakam down
24 to start the quarter only one starter
on the floor for toronto fred van vliet
here's ibaka on a rim run and it's
blocked by tatum
and scored just 11 points in that first
quarter
smart wide open for three
[Music]
you see the raptors pretty much playing
a zone right now
smart again three three-pointers in the
opening three minutes from marcus smart
dice kicks it out tatum's chance from
the corner
i says it knocked away but it goes right
to brown who went down hard
stolen by brown and it'll be struggled
with the dribble brown gets inside and
lays it up and in
against down on obi pulls back lost the
handle here comes an inoby tatum in
pursuit and now but
he's not blocked the hall blocked by
tatum ball knocked out of bounds
oh what a sensational defensive play
to players 45 plus ball poked away
jalen brown throws it ahead to tatum
tatum goes up and throws it down
and boston draws first blood in the
second overtime
[Applause]
basket tatum and they don't want that
trend to change lowry looking for
a baca turnover transition finger roll
brown
foster in his 26th year zack zarba
and david guthrie 17 and 15 years in the
nba all the way out on the break
is brown and boston back in front
jalen brown scores the layup in
transition for 17 but
2 for 13 in the last eight minutes
there's a steal turnover toronto
here's brown on the take and brown
finishes with a foul
analytically speaking outstanding shots
but they're just not able to knock them
down consistently right now
smart up top for tatum smart got the
steal
and leaves it for jason tatum and boston
in transition
rebound this guy has really filled out
all aspects of his game the three-point
ball one of them and the celtics roaring
out to an eight-nothing lead
well a great start by the celtic smart
kicks it out wanna maker
shot clock down to four for kemba walker
jab steps on crowder
and it's nothing but nets had to deal
with tyson there
really good job getting the body on them
got tied up in traffic and turned it
over marcus smart
whistle foul counted it's just elite
athleticism and timing to get between
those
white jerseys walker with a quick sit
dribble
working on crowder got it kemba
nice feet inside and tice throws it down
kimbo walker beautiful wrap around
bounce pass by adebayo as a center
against
someone as clever with the ball ball
stripped
kemba walker with a steal on duncan
robinson drives goes reverse banks at
home
shot clock at six tatum
gets into the paint drives and finishes
oh beautiful move from tatum most
three-point field goals made for the
heat
jalen brown again goes to the basket
robinson had those six threes in game
two had that hot start had 12
of his 18 points in that first quarter
three-pointer that's good kemba walker
second possession of zone
tonight for miami walker gets plenty of
room
nails the three-pointer his second three
anything but normal in this nba bubble
shot blocked jalen brown throws it right
back at dragons
here's tatum runs oh and throws it down
first runs in the crowder and then the
hammer now the celtics up by
five still six eight six nine six nine
on that front line with haywood brown
and tatum
turnover butler couldn't handle a pass
tatum ahead of the path
and throws it down jason tatum puts the
celtics back up by
six brown comes over to help out shot
clock at seven
brown gets into the paint kicks it out
in the corner good open look
and grant williams right off the bench
the rookie knocks it down
hero again drives heroes got 20 points
but throws it away haywood beautiful
pass ahead to tatum
and tatum with the slam and the foul
kendrick nunn with a bad decision there
fakes a pass and comes up short rebound
tipped out walker looked to tip it to
haywood
but haywood went forward hero grabs it
drives block from behind by tatum
and it's still miami ball
kemba walker stops back up top tatum
pull-up two-pointer got it as the shot
clock expires
like in the previous game gets the nod
as jaylen brown through throws it in
that was it i think that was an attempt
at alley-oop to tice
out of by the free throws not showing
any ill effects from that left arm
injury
he suffered in game four jalen brown
nice move
count it and one sometimes as players
you got to give of yourself
bad pass from heroes stolen by tatum
tatum down the lane goes up lays it up
[Applause]
another steal this time it's walker
walker throws it out for hayward and
haywood banks at home
you think you'd figure it out six games
in so kudos to them
[Applause]
hero bad pass stolen by tatum tatum
ahead of the pack
goes up and throws it down
[Applause]
walker has some room and hits kimball
walker
a high arcing three-pointer rocket
strides inside misses
williams the rebound dragon story was
fouled
jalen brown head down to the rim lay-up
counted and one
chance for a three-point play as the
lead is cut to three
stolen by brown jalen brown ahead of the
pack and throws it down and boston
regains the lead